[Musica]
oggi vi parlerò di stereotipi femminili
di abbattimento degli stereotipi
femminili e per farlo utilizzerò la
musica che il campo di cui mi occupo e
utilizzerò anche l'immaginario e
l'iconografia che alla musica è legata
per fare questo vi chiedo però di
provare a fare un esercizio di
astrazioni
immaginiamoci tutti di essere degli
alieni che siamo atterrati in questo
momento qui sul pianeta terra a matera
nello specifico o dovunque voi siate
siamo atterrati ci impose siamo del
corpo di qualcun altro
entriamo l'invasione degli ultracorpi e
parliamo di femminile siamo a guardarsi
intorno per cercare di capire il mondo
della donna
questa cosa di essere dentro un fisico
che non riconosciamo esattamente come
nostra un'esperienza che tutti abbiamo
vissuto in un periodo della nostra vita
piuttosto preciso cioè quando capitava
che andavamo a dormire che eravamo
bambini e bambine e ci svegliavamo che
eravamo ragazzini e ragazzine di colpo
il nostro fisico cambia facevamo la voce
che diventavano acuta che avevamo per i
che spuntavano in più parti del corpo e
altri cambiamenti e soprattutto non
riconoscevamo tutti quelli che avevamo
in intorno a partita dai genitori ma
anche ai nostri compagni di scuola
noi oggi siamo degli alieni
però diciamo che anche gli adolescenti
in qualche modo sono alieni e alien
adolescenti hanno una caratteristica in
comune ce l'ha spiegata prima ho provato
prima a spiegarlo facendo quella quel
jingle che è quello di casey le
spielberg ha scelto per incontri
ravvicinati del terzo tipo
quando appunto ci ha raccontato che gli
alieni utilizzano per comunicare un
unico sistema la musica che in qualche
modo è stato anche il primo sistema che
noi umani
abbiamo scelto per comunicare quindi
siamo alieni siamo sul pianeta terra
usiamo la musica
adesso c'è un modo unico per fare questo
prendiamo uno smartphone ipad un
computer un televisore e vediamo video
musicali vediamo immagini musica non
cercano di capire cos'è la donna se
partiamo dall'italia
siamo in italia lo spettacolo che ci
appare questo qua
citando un altro film la ragazza della
porta accanto le artiste hanno scelto di
abbattere completamente la distanza che
c'è tra artista e spettatore presentarti
esattamente come se fossero delle
spettatrici in qualche modo si sono dei
sessualizzati cioè come un po com'era
con le barbie e bg meno che per i
vestiti sotto non c'era niente e se
proviamo andare invece dall'altra parte
della manica dall'altra parte
dell'oceano lo spettacolo a cui
assisteremo è molto diverso questo
mi fermo proprio su queste immagini qui
e non a caso anche se analizziamo i
testi delle canzoni
lo spettacolo è esattamente lo stesso
nonostante l'italiano sia una lingua
decisamente più ricca di sfumature di
parole dell'inglese i testi delle
canzoni pop italiani di questo momento
sono fondamentalmente basate su una
trentina di vocaboli piuttosto
elementari e ruotano tutti intorno a un
unico concetto che a quello dei
sentimenti
il corpo è sparito e i sentimenti hanno
occupato tutto lo spazio disponibile
dall'altra parte nonostante appunto
l'inglese sia decisamente più debole
come lingua
le artiste anche nelle artiste che
abbiamo visto adesso ma quelle che
vedremo fra poco hanno deciso di
attaccare lo stereotipo femminile uno
stereotipo basato su tre principi
fondamentalmente la donna deve essere
perfetta fisicamente per perfetta
significa entra per rientrare in
determinati canoni stabiliti altrove
deve essere sempre giovane e deve essere
accogliente queste artiste hanno deciso
di abbattere un pezzetto alla volta
questo stereotipo casson di canzoni e
anche a suon di immaginario avete visto
delle immagini forti ma sono immagini
forti che non rientrano nello stereotipo
di donna che vi ho appena descritto
adesso cercherò di andare un po più
nello specifico per accompagnarvi in
questo ragionamento
lei è to be lu dove lo si scrive ma il
nome ha detto to be lu un artista
svedese di cannes piuttosto successo in
america
l'immagine che vedete in questo momento
cioè lei che alza la maglietta e
favorire il seno è un classico dei suoi
concerti perché perché tuvalu che è un
artista appunto che arrivata anche prima
in classifica negli stati uniti ha
deciso dal suo secondo album che si
chiamava le di wood è la cui copertina
c'era la sua mano che si infilavano i
suoi jeans e le dvd significa bagnarsi
quindi insomma un messaggio piuttosto
chiaro non c'è un mare o non c'era un
rubinetto
se si capisce di cosa sta parlando
lei ha deciso che il centro della sua
poetica sarebbe stato il diritto della
donna la gratificazione sessuale quindi
passare da essere oggetto di desiderio a
desiderate è stato un tentativo che è
riuscito perché questo messaggio lo ha
portato a milioni di persone e far altro
questo che vedete adesso è il suo logo
che la o del suo nome ma come potete
vedere chi si intende di design uno di
design insomma potrà intuire di cosa si
tratta
ci sono altre artiste che hanno fatto lo
stesso tipo di percorsi in maniera forse
anche più eclatante una lei hannah
montana chiunque sia stato ragazzino
recentemente o abbia avuto dei ragazzi
in gara recentemente la conosce eroina
della disney personaggio molto amato
figlia del cantante country billy ray
cyrus
un certo giorno dopo per essere stata
per tanto tempo impianta sa bene dentro
i televisioni di tutte le famiglie del
mondo occidentale si è presentata così
ai video music award al 2013
il simpatico omino che state sue spalle
si chiama robin thicke è un cantante pop
lei si è presentata e ha dato vita a
questa danza che per un po è diventata
anche piuttosto famose che si chiama to
air king ovverosia strofinava nel sedere
sui suoi genitali
nel farlo mostrava la lingua in quel
modo lì piuttosto sguaiato ma quasi
fumettistico perché perché miley cyrus
hannah montana ricordiamo la fino a quel
momento lei era hannah montana come se
fosse stata più retta o un altro di
questi personaggi della disney ha deciso
di mettere in scena e l'ha fatto per
capirsi quel momento è come se fosse la
finale del nostro festival di sanremo
l'ha fatto su un palco ha detto io vi
faccio vedere che i bambini a un certo
punto diventano adolescenti e quindi
scoprono il sesso
l'ha fatto pubblicamente e un altro
piccolo tassello dello stereotipo della
dorna passiva quindi oggetto di
desiderio non desiderate è crollato non
felice cioè non paga di aver fatto solo
questo ha deciso di andare avanti ha
fatto questa campagna che siamo a
frieden apple letteralmente liberalità
pezzo in cui diceva siccome il corpo
della donna non ha gli stessi diritti
del corpo dell'uomo perché in qualche
modo è inferiore
noi siamo solamente un oggetto passivo
non siamo mai attivo io pretendo che i
miei capelli abbiano gli stessi diritti
dei capezzoli di un uomo
fateci riusare perché se togliamo il
contesto erotico che vuole quindi che
qualsiasi cosa noi mostriamo sia solo a
beneficio dell'uomo
in questo momento il nostro corpo
assumerà dei diritti che ha al momento
non ci sono campagne strane come queste
ce ne sono diverse penso alla campagna
free riding che è quella delle donne che
vogliono andare in giro durante il
periodo delle mestruazioni stanza
pannolino po sembra sostanza assorbendo
ho usato un anconetani smo scusate una
campagna decisamente interessante su
questo fronte ha fatto amanda palmer
amanda palmer e le juve questa è una
porzione di amanda palmer che ha fatto
una canzone che si chiama una pop
tasmania ma può tasmania è un brano in
cui si spiega che la mappa della
tasmania questo significa chiaramente il
titolo è esattamente uguale al monte di
venere e in tutto il video lei appare
sempre così mostrandolo una volta c'è
l'urlo di munch a una volta ci sono dei
soldi dei lego insomma varie facesse
tutto questo perché perché lei è contro
la depilazione imposta alle donne
anche questa può sembrare una
stupidaggine ma è sempre un modo per
rivendicare una consapevolezza del
proprio fisico e per non lasciare che
avere diritto di veto sul fisico delle
donne siano gli uomini
peraltro proprio l'altro ieri è uscita
la copertina del suo prossimo disco che
uscirà a marzo è questa come vedete
continua a essere contraria alla
depilazione nei canoni moderni e usa il
suo corpo in maniera molto
come dire potente e c'è una artista però
che più di tutti ha fatto qualcosa su
questo fronte lei lady gaga questa non è
lei l'altra una statua di jeff koons
artista dell'arte pop che l'ha ritratta
lady gaga mostrandosi in questo modo
cioè con un cyborg sessuato ma al tempo
stesso un avatar non fisico
ha imposto il suo tipo di di essere il
suo aspetto che non è perfetto per
karmaso importante alle linee le curve
che non sarà esattamente quelle che
corrispondono ai canoni vincenti e lo ha
imposto talmente tanto video dopo video
canzone da un pò canzone che è diventata
lei stessa lei che voleva essere attiva
oggetto di desiderio nella sua
imperfezione
al punto che tutti quelli che si
ritenevano imperfetti negli stati uniti
ma non solo in occidente si sono
riconosciuti in lei play a milioni di
fan che si fanno chiamare li del monster
piccoli mostri e questa cosa è
decisamente un grande passo per
l'abbattimento degli stereotipi in
italia dove abbiamo avuto gianna nannini
che cantava un inno alla masturbazione
femminile nel 1979 con america abbiamo
avuto patty pravo che canta va pensiero
stupendo
tutto questo si è fermato nei primi anni
zero quando pare chiara hanno fatto una
canzone che parlava di diritto la
gratificazione sessuale esattamente come
tuvalu che è incappato nella censura del
moige hanno fatto ritirare il loro disco
perché era considerato troppo forte con
una ragione di donne non devono dire che
hanno diritto a ago dire la loro
carriera che ha una carriera molto
importante è crollata e da quel momento
nessun artista italiana si è più esposta
in contemporanea considerate che se stai
è partito tutto il fenomeno della
certificazione della donna da parte del
cosiddetto berlusconismo olgettine naomi
noemi e la d'addario ruby la nipote di
mubarak e per contro se non ora quando
il corpo della donna della zanardo e di
colpo il corpo della donna è in qualche
modo scomparso faccio un salto temporale
siamo a cavallo tra il novecento l'anno
mille lei è lady godiva qui nel quadro
di john koller la storia la conoscete le
offrì co dico e ponte di coventry il suo
marito alza le tasse il popolo insorge
perché è reso la fame lei sfila col
popolo una donna che si rivela al marito
inaudito il marito la sfida dice ok
se tu sfilerà in usa per il paese io a
questo punto toglierò le tasse godiva
accetta sarà cavallo si sfoglia e
attraversa tutta com entry il fatto che
una donna utilizza il proprio corpo per
vincere le guerre è un fenomeno che c'è
sempre stato sia nella cultura classica
quella greca quella latina sera una
cultura celtica e dei paesi scandinavi
questa statua qui che stava museo
internazionale di napoli e la venere
callipigia sia la vendita dalle belle
natiche che è una venere che a
differenza di quella di botticelli che
si copre si mostra era un modo per
vincere le guerre ci sono tante leggende
di guerre vinte non dai guerrieri ma
dalle donne che si alzavano la gonna di
fronte agli avversari addirittura di
mareggiate fermate da donne esattamente
alla stessa maniera nel momento in cui
gli uomini erano largo nelle barche lady
godiva fa esattamente la stessa cosa ma
per farlo ha bisogno di un uomo peeping
tom tom il guardone che colui che
contravviene alla regola che aveva
imposto il marito cioè ha detto che ti
passi nuda però cita però nessuno ti può
guardare murate tutte le mura tutte le
finestre tutte le porte peeping tom la
guarda lei donna potente che desidera
vince e fa vincere la guerra
quella che vedete adesso alle mie spalle
è il momento in cui qualcuno ha deciso
in italia è uno dei momenti in cui
qualcuno ha deciso in italia di
resistere a questa guerra di stereotipi
cui siamo stati sottoposti
loro sono la rappresentante di lista una
band siciliana che proprio oggi in
questo momento è uscita con un album che
si chiama go go diva ovverosia un
omaggio e dico ti va nel fare questo
hanno deciso di esporsi fisicamente sono
un maschio e una femmina dario e
veronica e hanno fatto una canzone che
siamo a questo corpo che canta
esattamente quello di cui abbiamo
parlato fino adesso il diritto della
donna di essere se stessa quindi anche
in perfetta e di non essere violentata
da il bombardamento di immagini e di
indicazioni che qualche uomo ha deciso
di dare alle donne creando quello
stereotipo di perfezione
di giovinezza e di accoglienza ma c'è
anche un'altra artista che ha fatto
questa è la fatto stupendi in qualche
modo quel tipo di percorso lei ilaria
porceddu che ha partecipato alla prima
stagione di xfactor e partecipando alla
prima stagione di xfactor che stava per
vincere ma ha vinto moralmente non ha
vinto nei fatti è incappata in un
discografico che ha deciso che per farle
avere successo doveva posare in maniera
sexy per maxim magazine questa cosa
ovviamente la disturbata perché lei non
era tanto nuda quando era spogliata in
qualche modo si è fermata e ha deciso di
fare un'operazione voluto precisa se
prima tagliati i capelli cercando di
imbruttirsi tra l'altro neanche
riuscendoci
e poi ha fatto un altro tipo di
operazione ha fatto un video di una
canzone che siamo mai mai in cui si
mostra completamente nuda insieme una
signora più anziana una bambina creano
del ciclo della vita perché in quel modo
prendeva lo stereotipo che era stato
imposterò accantonava poi ha fatto un
disco in cui ha deciso di cantare il
corpo della donna senza tenere conto
degli stereotipi c'è una canzone va nel
suo disco che parla di una donna che
decide di essere libera esattamente come
bocca di rosa di de andré ma dal punto
di vista femminile
e c'è un'altra canzone che si chiama
tabula rasa in cui si parla di sesso al
femminile dal punto di vista di una
donna
bene ancora una volta lady godiva
ovverosia una donna che usa il suo corpo
usa se stessa per vincere la guerra
[Musica]
i pensieri diversi sono romane levatura
fare
scompare
a una pioggia sottile questo beninteso e
scendere il nesso tra mou e peccato
risponderà lento di ben definito un
cristallo sospesa sopra un umore rete
[Musica]
toccare con mano il capogiro dell'uomo a
forza di cenare insieme
[Musica]
pietro
non c'è le veloci come le sale la merda
barone
vedremo
male
[Musica]
le basi per noi uguali diversi
come la piazza
[Musica]
orgasmo cancelli
ma il mio dovere
ben presto
sei bello che fisso tra un angolo retto
le di serena
io ricordo
ma
[Musica]
vabbè
pm
[Musica]
all
teramo
ed il cuore non c'è
è una tabula rasa
[Musica]
[Applauso]